first question bill kristol would you
vote for Hillary if Trump is the nominee
ooh tough good one folks that prefer not
to vote for either so I'd like to find a
real Republican to vote for but if that
doesn't happen if it is Trump and
Hillary would you stay home or vote for
a trap I know you wouldn't vote for
Trump right I'm trying to recruit a
Republican to rock so no I'm serious
come on it's past the conventions its
Trump and Hillary what do you do you're
gonna have to face this I know you
thought of facing I'll face it on
November sixth or eighth or whatever
lecture you're not gonna decide to get
in the booth why is Hillary Hillary's
really that bad she's really that evil
is pretty bad
she's pretty to be honest it really can
you see ways she's not evils you'd like
you you must you don't want Hillary
Clinton is president and if you're real
conservative you don't want Donald you
can't really picture Hillary with a
table full of steaks behind her can it I
dreamt that I granted that Jane is there
any legal action that can be taken
against the Koch brothers
well one legal action is confirming a
Supreme Court justice who might overturn
Citizens United
that's gonna be an animating
this election day well I mean they're
not gonna let Obama pick one right which
it go of course they'll pick one they
weren't right and meet the person right
right which is of course what they
always do cheat it's cheating
um but you know that's that's gonna get
people upset the dissents we bring on
both sides I think for the first time
okay
has the Obama doctrine been a successful
foreign policy I don't even know what
the Obama doctrine is except maybe don't
do stupid [ __ ] number he said that don't
do stupid [ __ ] III that's the what by
the way that is what I'm gonna miss most
about him yeah no new stupid foreign
wars didn't take the bait every time
they leading from behind very unworthy
thousand people deficit might have been
Aston tried and that was all his fault
because Syria was a paradise but Libyan
Libya has not been Libya has not been a
successful foreign venture right that's
kind of I love the way they pretend that
the Middle East is a perfectly
manageable place and it's all about why
did he the very difficult place I never
said was all Obama's fault okay you
can't say it was that that's a success
Syria in Iraq it's horrible but what
could anyone else have done you could
have intervened early and helps you
intervene with troops on the ground in
Syria we certainly could have helped the
resistance to Assad and had there were
plenty but the resistance Democrats
there who's the resistance you know they
tried to find a moderate army they went
up with five guys that's not a joke five
guys and you know your war in Iraq went
so well uh
in fact if they had wanted by having
this management we have won it by the
end of 2011 to bait some other time okay
we had we had yeah I know Bhama sense I
want to be right there right but but he
didn't smirk that was that was it that
was that Bush failed to succeed failed
to to to carry out to be able to
negotiate a Status of Forces Agreement
which Bush didn't negotiate either in
2008 that was a mistake on question okay
but I mean it seems like the answer is
we have to stay in these places forever
to make them work yeah well you know
there's a some degree as we did in Korea
as we did in Germany should we should
there is a fascinating article out right
now by the Atlantic's Jeffrey Goldberg
where he talks about the don't do stupid
[ __ ] line and I think Obama was sort of
incredulous that people thought it was
somehow controversial not to do stupid
[ __ ] like that should be because it's an
excuse for doing nothing
oh no get slaughtered that's what they
don't do stupid [ __ ] in Rwanda is that
was that a good policy or an action
warning you're okay with admitting that
the stupid [ __ ] is already apologized
meaning the stupid the power Linda said
right the stupor wanted right then I
open my to accept I really never
intervening you can intervene and do
smart [ __ ] what he's saying is you have
to know when to intervene and when to do
it appropriately and that's what his
doctrine is I don't think it's maybe I
thought the only time I was in the Obama
White House is when I supported the
intervention in Libya beside iddin want
to see how does the thousands people get
slaughtered and I thought there's a
chance to have a decent outcome in Libya
no Sam's right ice not there was no
follow-up by us by the Europeans and now
it's a terrible place so if you're
serious about helping people have doing
things around the world you've got to be
willing to stay the course but you know
what one of the things Obama says in
this article is the hardest decisions to
make are sometimes not to go to war when
you have so much of a drumbeat of people
pushing you do you know that
yeah you know that even Mormon
missionaries won't go to Syria well now
no one would go there obviously ok
billions Syria is it Europe now alright
Maria how can the average American
safeguard themselves from being the
victim of fraud your fraud is at
all-time record level especially because
of the internet right it is and
absolutely is I think the number one
thing we can do is apply the if it's too
good to be true it is doctrine to
ourselves and we never want to apply it
to ourselves because when it's happening
to us it's just wonderful right right
it's only too good for other people so I
mean the the scams yeah people fall for
I've gotten that uh you know the message
from somebody you know and it says hey
I'm over here in overseas and I need you
to send me five hundred dollars you sent
it of course no no no but the first time
I got it I was I almost did because it
never happened before right and somebody
looked at it went oh this called this
person back and ask them any question
about it who they really see if they
know you yeah I mean the journalistic
victim trust but verify right because
our first our first impulse is always to
trust especially if emotions are high
right so like during the elections right
everyone is really riled up but why your
eyes don't it and when you're emotional
you're not you're not logical right not
reasonable and you start acting rather
than thinking and taking that moment to
reflect might actually save you from
sending five hundred dollars and what
when so you're not supposed to send the
money
well if to me you can send okay fine
yeah
yeah when Trump he talked about how they
love their country look I mean it seems
a little over the top or something I
mean we all love our country but it
seems a little erotic yeah it does the
wet also when you read with the raw
steaks whole line they'll take you out I
mean I read this poll that only 11
percent of Republicans say Obama loves
the country the right way that's what
creepy isn't it there is a right way so
good at convincing people that his is
the right way I mean every single one of
his statements how can you argue with
them they're all so wonderful you know a
little creepy though that he said that
he would also date his daughter if maybe
too much of this campaign going on it
that is an amazing book in itself how
Trump is successful with women voters
because it's not like he's not and you
know sexist alert I know people are
gonna object to this but sorry women
like confidence they do I don't think
that sexist to say right women like
confidence I think men like confidence
to I think everyone likes confidence men
like people it's just us you're better
with men so and like it's a Republican
women that they're resisting Trump more
than Republican man I would say that but
it's it's not an equivalent women and
men are different come on men they liked
it and they like beauty and they like
ass and they like new you know I mean
Ashley Madison when would that was
hacked we found out this was the
cheating site for married couples 37
million men 12 thousand women if that
doesn't work I'll you everything you
need or no they're saying they like new
to they didn't want it another Clinton
and rocket you know and they didn't want
another Bush they want they want new I
want strange and they're getting it with
Trump all right should Hillary Clinton
released the transcripts of her speeches
to Goldman Sachs obviously really yeah
what could she be saying there if it
doesn't if it's nothing then why not
what could it be I'm sure there was some
like nice language but probably nothing
damning that she said to some bankers
that she probably wouldn't say in the
trail I'm I would bet if I had to bet I
would bet that there's really nothing
damaging there but they're very
protective that campaign they don't like
to be bullied into doing something I
just think they should just get it up
I'm gonna say it I said it last week on
the show she if she's the nominee has to
pick Elizabeth Warren as the vice
president sounds like this this is this
is the smart move energize the base and
take the Wall Street issue off the table
they also mentioned sherrod Brown as a
possible to come to boring great guy but
it's just more boring the same that
excites exactly nobody any and and
Hillary already excites exactly no but
not it I mean fairness Trump excites
people those Bund rallies Bernie
yes we know you have been saying his
name Sam why has polling been so
unreliable and one of the tools should
the media used to report on the election
well I think I know but go ahead there's
a there's a technical answer here
polling in a primary is really difficult
sometimes the methodology you know you
can end up doing you know phones versus
online polling there's different reasons
that it's unreliable in some states
there aren't really good pollsters I
mean is a very boring answer but you
also have to keep in mind that polling
is not necessarily supposed to be
predictive it's a it's a snapshot in
time and so you're trying to pick up
trends along the way but isn't it also
because it's hard to reach Millennials I
mean they did not get Bernie Bernie
support in Michigan at all I mean some
polls had him down by over 30 points and
he won that race and I think that's
because that's why you got a look every
online poll you mention Sanders number
183 percent okay yeah and I do the math
in your head that's me that's like
triple his margin it's Hillary won by
about eight points among voters thirty
and over right so that is actually a
pose we're showing so they didn't
capture they did was they don't have a
way to yeah I mean pollsters are trying
to incorporate more cell phones into
their surveys the online surveys which
were once terribly unreliable have
become more reliable now that more
people are doing stuff online but it's a
changing because they still do it by
landline
a lot of the polls he goes do you know
who's entering landlines their parents
the guy who punched the black guy all
right thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen